Thing is the Addams Family's…pet?
Handservant?
Whatever he is, he plays a big role in Netflix's
"Wednesday."
Thing steals the scene whenever he appears.
As he's portrayed by Victor Dorobantu, he
can convey emotions through just his movement.
You can tell when he's angry or being smug.
He may be just a hand, but his physical mannerisms
make him feel like a whole person.
Thing clearly cares about Wednesday, and his
loyalty is unshakable, even when he doesn't
agree with her actions.
In the episode where Wednesday finds Thing
impaled by a knife and bleeding to death,
there's a palpable tension.
Thankfully Uncle Fester is able to save Thing
using his electromagnetic powers, but it's
a close call.
Thing is not only Wednesday's partner in crime,
he's also the voice of reason.
But only in a metaphorical sense, of course.